everything that is running our society's
attention right now Facebook and YouTube
and Instagram and Snapchat and Twitter
and everything 12 years ago did not
exist the smartphone did not exist Uber
did not exist Airbnb did not accept
nothing the reason I wish he could take
everybody back is we do not have context
it's tough It's hard for us to
understand how different it is for us
than the prior two generations it's
difficult because you have no context to
anything else but the stakes and
opportunity are all time our great
grandkids everybody else will look back
at this era as the moment and so I
implore you to take a step back and
really fundamentally ask yourself a
couple questions one what Legacy are you
building because it will be the leverage
for everything that you want over the
next 60 years and that is based on your
actions and two are you squeezing the
out of this moment as much as you
can